imaginez qu'on amène votre enfant
l'hôpital sans vous et qu'on vous
apprendre votre enfant est décédé sans
vous montrer son corps ou pire en vous
montrant le corps d'un autre enfant
décédé et vous savez très bien que c'est
pas le vôtre et vous découvrez des
années plus tard qu'on le donner en
adoption à votre insu on peut
difficilement imaginer quelque chose de
plus épouvantables mais ça s'est passé
ici au québec et des familles de
différentes communautés autochtones de
différentes nations même m'ont appelé
pour me raconter leurs histoires
d'enfants disparus
est ce aussi venue à la suite de
reportages qu'on avait diffusé il ya
deux ans et qui racontait l'histoire de
neuf enfants inouk avait envoyé à
l'hôpital de blanc-sablon des années 70
et qui était jamais revenu alors pour
s'en rappeler de ce reportage
voici l'extrait
aqua chipie 1972 une petite communauté
de 80 autochtone habite au bord de la
rivière saint-augustin en
basse-côte-nord les idées viennent tout
juste d'entrer dans leur première maison
encore hier il vivait sous la tente et
est un nomade il n'y avait pas demandé
ce qu il était mal dans leur maison y'a
même pas se mettre la tête dans ses
besoins
cette année là plusieurs enfants tombent
malades et patates on est tous c'est
beaucoup il faisait de la fièvre
on n'était plus sous la tente il y avait
des maisons à ce moment là on a eu les
enfants sont évacués par la voie des
airs
car il n'y a pas de route vers l'hôpital
de blanc sablon à 200 kilomètres seul
sans leurs parents un but à chaque fois
qu'un de mes enfants a été hospitalisé
on m'interdisait de la compagnie d'une
en principe en quelques mois
neuf enfants vont ainsi partir neuf pour
une si petite communauté
autant dire une saignée jeu le savoir
puisqu'il se pensait vraiment
est-ce que sont décédés ou une maladie
ou ses enfants on les reverra jamais
tellement touche à ce reportage
anne et la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'elle
enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones assassinées et disparues
hors prix certains des éléments de votre
reportage pour pousser plus loin lankais
et à la suite de ce reportage là vous
avez commencé à recevoir d'autres
appellent d'ailleurs dans d'autres
communautés
oui j'avais décidé de simplement les
aider ces familles là pas c'est plus
facile pour moi de faire des recherches
dans les archives médicales que pour
elle qui sont loin qui parlent pas
toujours très bien français mais lorsque
j'ai vu l'ampleur de la situation et du
problème et j'ai décidé de faire un
deuxième reportage
[Musique]
quand je lis appelé mon petit ange pour
le garçon
pierre du
[Musique]
petite fille et lui donne comme en mal
martha vient de loin pour honorer la
mémoire de ces enfants
enfin il retrouvé lé attikamek de
manawan en haute mauricie
il y a quelques mois elle nous racontait
son drame
j'ai été évacué en urgence
beauchemin cinq jours à l'hôpital de
joliette
[Musique]
l'admission de la vigueur
chacun un cap atteint les élus vivent
chacun dans l'incubateur c'était en 1971
c'est la dernière fois qu'elle est verra
le médecin lui a dit que les jumeaux
n'avait pas survécu
mais elle ne les a pas vus morts je n'ai
eu ni certificat de décès ni la
déclaration de naissance un doute
s'installe à sa demande nous avons
cherché des documents et retracer des
rapports d'autopsié 5,71 star violon et
d'après nos recherches ces jus monstre
est enterré ici au cimetière de joliette
dans une fosse commune pour les corps
non réclamés
mais à notre étonnement cela ne suffit
pas à convaincre martin maintenant avec
les avis de décès que nous
trouver puis rapport d'autopsié est ce
que vous pensez que vos enfants sont
morts les rapports que j'ai eu c'est
l'accord encore un autre bébé la petite
loreana auraient été enterrés ici en
1973 mais ses soeurs en doute également
le fait que c'est pas la presse anne
laure diana avaient été évacuées de
manouane vers joliette pierre paul
raconte les preuves de ses beaux parents
les parrains ont été obligés de revenir
à la main droite
ils ont laissé le fil à ben ali ont reçu
téléphone comme de quoi les loggias
allait bien quelques jours après ils
apprennent que l'enfant est décédé ils
ont pu se déplacer pour voir leur fille
km en hydravion mais l'impensable se
produit on vu un enfant acteur plus
grande que lorient n'a jusque elle que
moi qui est l'auteur de la la voix un
appui en vie mais c'est pas notre fille
que la personne était là j'ai dit oui
c'est votre fille puis à fermer le
cercle de plus lorient n'a est encore
sur la liste des indices inscrit comme
si elles étaient vivantes mais est ce
suffisant pour remettre en question le
papier officiel de décès j'étais moi
même emmené à l'extérieur fait ça parce
que j'étais malade c'est avec l'histoire
délice que nous commençons à comprendre
leur méfiance par ses proches dans sa
part l'autre alice avait besoin de
chirurgie à la hanche
elle a séjourné seul à l'hôpital de
joliette les parents d'élise avait
accepté de la laisser un temps en ville
pour obtenir des soins par l'abandonner
à une autre famille au parlement marion
dit non il n'est pas question et 10e ma
fille mais par amour à partie sonore
alès elle a été rescapé mais d'autres
enfants se sont volatilisés envoyé à
l'hôpital pour être soigné
ils ont disparu pendant des années
parfois pour toujours
c'est ainsi que la petite diana disparu
pendant des années sa famille a dit
qu'un mec nous accueillent leur
campement pour raconter ce qui s'est
passé mais on me l'a volé on nous envoie
les nôtres sans ça qu'on dit l'instant à
peu près ça fait penser aux résultats
elle a dit que quand car son bébé est
tombé malade il y avait à peu près six
mois et qui ont comme rester je sais pas
combien de jours en veillant sur diane
basket soulman est là s'attendait kim à
son bébé
finalement ils ont réussi à demande un
avion et sont allés à la tuque
tiens et évacué seul sans sa mère
c'était la norme à l'époque elle ait pu
me monique qui nécessite de la garder un
temps à l'hôpital de la tuque mais elle
s'est volatilisée placé dans une famille
blanche sans le consentement de ses
parents
un autre revers documents sociaux
j'arrive le papier placements d'enfants
je fais vraiment marqué avant dans des
parents
j'emmenais ce document la mama j'ai
traduit le document de a ha se souvenait
qu'elle avait signé un document mais
c'est le curé lui disais c'est pourquoi
puce est soigné c'est pour ça faut
devait signer ce document la peau du
taux pareil c'est pas la même chose
j'imagine que votre mère est désiré
récupère et lance à lui deux phases oui
c'est ça alors de six mois jusqu'à
peut-être 5,6 en ayant comme pas eu de
contact mais elle a l'espérait toujours
de recevoir à qui vous allez pouvoir ni
chercher l'enfant qui savent n'est pas
le seul moyen qui avait pour avoir des
nouvelles de départ le chef et par le
curé aussi pourquoi parce que les autres
vivent sur le territoire cac avait la
chance d'aller au village de saint marc
pour l'épicerie ou des choses comme ça
va y aller chercher l'information
on n'imagine pas l' isolement de ces
communautés dans les années 70 encore
semi nomades sur les territoires de
chasse une partie de la nuit sous les
tentes l'autre dans des cabanes sans
électricité encore moins de téléphone
pour se rendre en ville il fallait qu à
noter et portage et des jours jusqu'au
chemin de fer et les années soit la
tuque soit amos
de passage à l'hôpital pour accoucher
alice la mère qui ne parle pas français
questionne tout de même les infirmières
et une fois ils ont dit avait pas de
voie café oublie là n'avaient pas de
voir sa fille c'est un gars a fait le
point
des propos repris par un blanc au
village qui avait le téléphone si
précieux oubliez taf est en eux d'autres
enfin faisant d'autres encore mieux aux
lilas elle m'a mal avait répondu non
c'est quand même mon enfance et ma fait
pj jeu quand même attaché à un juge veut
la garder les enfants y sont vraiment
aimé qu'ils sont vraiment couvé à la
vedette de passe et qu'il marque repas
au pana à mme diane béliveau ait engagé
dans les années 70 pour mettre sur pied
de véritables services sociaux à manawan
elle témoigne de la mentalité de
l'époque fut dans les hôpitaux souvent
en prise à des signalements équipe qui
était pas justifié que ce pressing
allemand zafar iqbal ce pas finalement
parce que la fin est l'épée bulot si
vous visez lieu avec les mouches noires
que le bol de ce que vous dites mais peu
brillant à la ferme blanc au caveau tir
n'avait sauté mépris et trouvait que si
eux considéraient que la fin est très a
besoin de protection quand de vrais ceux
se met à terre et le faire ce qui me
choque c'est que les ressources
infantiliser les paras c'est la façon
dont tu es se sont regardés les parents
autochtones depuis longtemps marie
pierre bousquet et la directrice du
programme d'études autochtone à
l'université de montréal
tous ces peuples là ont réussi à vivre
parfois dans des conditions très hostile
pendant des siècles en se débrouillant
parfaitement bien et c'était pas des
enfants
c'était des gens qu'ils avaient des
savoirs qu'ils étaient capables de gérer
des choses très compliquées au quotidien
de rendre la justice des pipes tout ce
système les a traités comme des gens
incapables de gérer eux mêmes ils soient
urbains du moins jeunes u15 puis gea
world yann j'ai toujours bien gardé
dans les communautés du québec
les enfants sont partout avec leur jeu
et le rire les enfants volés n'ont pas
été oubliés mais jusqu'ici les parents
les ont pleuré un silence après la pause
l'histoire de la disparition de diane
connaît un dénouement inespéré
[Musique]
te
il n'y a pas une communauté attikamek
pas une famille qui n'a pas connu la
souffrance de perdre la trace d'un
enfant que l'on soit au pitch i want
wiimote achiou manawan
il suffit de tendre l'oreille et le
micro pour entendre l'histoire d'enfants
volés comme celle du frère de susan
marcel qui a disparu de l'hôpital d'amos
et qui a été retrouvé à montréal
des années plus tard c'était juste pour
un bras cassé les parties plusieurs amis
comment ça se fait qu'il se retrouvèrent
montréal avec un bras cassé sa liquide
et déjà sur une liste en option une
chance qu'on l'a réussi à le retrouver à
temps sinon on l'aurait fait de dieu
sézanne se souvient du retour de son
frère moi j'étais à l'école je parte
c'est tout de suite à la maison b quand
je dis revue jésuite et avait grandi et
puis il parlait un anglais je pouvais
pas lui parler aux prêts n'est pas ce
qu'il disait mais avait l'air tout
joyeux content d'être là autre famille
autre disparition
je pense qu'il n'a pays sa soeur
pierrette est né à l'hôpital de la tuque
le cordon autour du cou elle avait
besoin de soins mais surprise lorsque le
père va la visite est hélas distincts
mais ont posé des questions médecins
comme maire en colère ou ce qui est
parti à lever de mon père ils l'ont
retrouvé dans une famille d'accueil à 15
km de là ils savaient même pas été placé
là c'est aussi au moins avertit ma mère
mon père
l'enfant a ensuite été envoyé à
l'hôpital à montréal les parents ont
réussi à la visite et jusqu'à ces deux
ans mais un jour le curé les adaptant à
l'arrivée du train
il se voit greffer est mort de maman et
si ça se peut pas elle est très très
bien donc on est parti de là bord il y
avait un train qui retourne
poil à montréal
quand qui ont voulu prendre le train le
curé de la brique manu arrêté ma mère
mon père pas qu'un bac dans les très
bien même si j'ai ma mère ma mère à se
débattait pour ramasser dans l'ue
pour aller voir ça - aller chercher
l'enterrer ici
avez vous un évident d un nom en doute
même chose pour le frère de jasmin
hospitalisés aussi à montréal en 1970 il
serait décédé quelques mois plus tard
ceux dont la dernière qui a appelé la
mère jamais de desservir tout ce temps
alors mamadou tall tu as pensé que ce
serait vivant et jamais des mornes
mais pourquoi pensez que votre frère
vous pouvez y vivent parce qu'il savait
les quatre soleil puis en plus ça leur
pendait des histoires comme ça là aussi
que dix enfants qui ont été enlevés puis
on leur avait dit que la rente amaury
les années plus tard j'ai trouvé je me
rappelle encore été testée maquis qu'on
lui dise cette amap qu'elle aimait
powder à l'airé la travailleuse sociale
and diane a elle même retrouvé vivant un
enfant pourtant déclaré mort est venue
ones nombre d'écoles venir manman avec
moi tullow modique et amant mais je
voudrais savoir où il est j'ai dit ce
que je recherchais mais je les trouvais
j'avais retrouvé n'est pas décédé du
tout mais il y avait été transférée dans
une ressource à mon frère tu vraiment
mais justice le rapport
c'est comme voler quelque chose à une
personne
qu'est ce qui a permis cette injustice
le ministère des affaires indiennes
avaient été émis une directive comme
dans le cas des pensionnats jamais
trouvé de directives particulières
concernant les enfants autochtones
mais ce genre de cas est assez commun
dans les communautés c'est pas les
médecins ou les travailleurs sociaux ou
les missionnaires ou les agents des
affaires indiennes qui prenait ce genre
de décision c'est une mentalité générale
déjà la tuque et moi moi ça fait
ballotter un monde assez tient là où
vous êtes
le no2 mondial parce que le ch et que sa
divine de quelle année à peu près du
crédit chargé du nord viviane au même
quotidien
eh oui diane a retracé sa famille a dit
québec à l'adolescence je voyais des
autochtones en vie où je n'avais pas que
ça me parle de chapeau qui est peu
d'amateurs à leur première rencontre
elle découvre toute une fratrie
promis qu'ils ont trouvé ces armes à
jacinthe est arrivé quand il faisait
juste en page 7 ans ferait ni montré
dans l'aréna stade qui me fera quelque
chose à raconter
ce moteur jumeaux le jumeau élevé sur la
réserve dans une langue inconnue de
diane le jeune je trouvais ça plus
difficile parce que je pouvais pas il
parlait alias km à paris le pôle alain
li a manca quelqu'un parle un manque de
quelque chose qu'on pourra jamais le
récupérer mais aussi la culture à la
peau pour mieux la culture beaucoup en
bois pillet on aurait aimé 5 à vienne
vivent ici belle
non c'est pas ça à voler leurs plus
beaux lieux aller vivre dans une grande
ville ces histoires d'enfants volés
entre les familles attikameks les
archives médicales que nous avons
retracé ne font pas le poids devant
l'espoir que les familles ont entretenu
pendant des années savons plus que sans
ça nous prend à la ville et est
quelqu'un qui préparent leurs beaux
jours pour dire moi je me souviens de ce
parfum là exactement elle les paroles de
leurs yamaha
[Musique]
ce qui est en jeu
la vérité concernant loreana nous
l'avons découvert après cette visite un
témoin de l'époque nous confirme que
l'enfant n'a pas été enterré dans la
fosse commune du cimetière comme on le
croyait
mais dans un champ à côté comme un chien
[Musique]
et en terminant à vous continuer de
recevoir de l'information sur des
enfants disparus
j'ai presque envie de dire et lens ce
qui veut dire que beaucoup plus de cas
que je ne l'imaginais au départ et là
les familles me disent que certains
surtout son collaborateur leur demande
même si la famille une requête à la cour
pour obtenir l'information
un obstacle de plus pour connaître la
vérité merci de la faire connaître cette
vérité sur ce drame des enfants
autochtones disparues
au nom de toute l'équipe je vous
remercie d'avoir est avec nous cette
semaine est revenu nous de la semaine
prochaine pour d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]